thank you very much thank you very much
well I've done my part for motion
pictures
I've stopped making them and so did the
writer of that screenplay he's gone back
to writing books his name is Irving
Wallace although I stopped making movies
I never stopped attending them in fact
ladies and gentlemen I'm enchanted by
the music I think it's consistently the
most original music written today mr.
Conte will you help me remind everyone
of this year's five nominees beginning
with Chariots of Fire
and from on Golden Pond
and Dragon Slayer
and from ride time
and from Raiders of the Lost Ark
thank you so much to discover who the
Academy is chosen the envelope will be
opened by the stars of body heat who
better to present the scoring Awards
then Kathleen Turner and William Hurt
ladies and gentlemen of the band they
identified the scores now let's identify
the men who compose them those five
gifted artists are Vangelis Chariots of
Fire
it's more for dragon's lair
Dave Grusin 4 on Golden Pond Randy
Newman for ragtime
when John Williams for Raiders of the
Lost Ark
the winner is the winner is
Vangelis
the Academy congratulate s' Vangelis and
accepts the award on his behalf
he'll get it on again soon